[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 votre
rendez-vous d'information sur TVfil 78
la rédaction vous propose ce soir un
nouveau débat autour du mariage pour
tous 15 jours après les opposants à ce
projet ces défenseurs doivent eux se
réunir dans la rue ce dimanche en
plateau Sandrine grangamb bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la responsable du PS
dans les ivelines également conseillère
régional et vous êtes favorable à
l'ouverture du mariage au couple
homosexuel tout comme Aurore berger à
vos côté bonsoir à vous chargé de
mission à l'UMP vous êtes l'une des
rares à l'UMP justement avoir fait part
de cette de cette position on verra ce
qu'en pense Alexy Biet bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le maire UMP de voisin le
Bretonneux Vous vous opposez donc à ce
changement ainsi que Benoît de
Saint-Cernin bonsoir membre du collectif
manif pour tous porte-parole de
l'association Les Adoptés égalementonsir
avant de vous laisser débattre voici les
Prin principaux titres de cette édition
quelquesuns des sujets que nous allons
développer au cours de la prochaine
heure les étudiants de l'université de
versaill 50 ans yeline mobilisé à
l'appel de l'UNEF pour préparer la
manifestation de dimanche en faveur du
mariage pour tous vous entendrez
d'ailleurs sa présidente et ses
explications ville locale le quartier
garbecane à la verrière est un projet
très attendu cela faisait 40 ans qu'il
n'y avait eu aucune construction dans
cette ville des réunions de concertation
se mett en place tisser le lien
intergénérationnel entre les très jeunes
enfants et les pensionnaires d'une
maison de trite c'est l'objectif de
l'association les petits ateliers de
Benjamin à Montini le bretonneuse ses
responsables seront aussi en plateau
tout à l'heure pour nous en dire plus et
puis du sport les footballeuses de
Montini le Bretonneux qui devait
disputer un match de Coupe de France ce
weekend face au PSG il a été annulé à
cause du mauvais temps vous le voyez
mais les solutions de remplacement
proposé par la fédération ne sont pas au
goût du coach local et puis à noter en
seconde partie d'émission à point un
complet sur l'économie la chronique de
l'cho avec Catherine zulato le mariage
pour tous présentation du projet projet
de loi le 29 janvier et nouveau débat
sur TV fil à suivre dès à
présent pour entamer les discussions
voici une phrase elle est signée de la
porte-parole du gouvernement la voici la
détermination du président Hollande à
faire voter le mariage pour tous c'est
évidemment sans faille et elle a ajouté
que ce serait le message donné demain
aux opposants qui doivent échanger avec
lui à l'Élysée qu'en pens Benoît de
Saint-Cernin et Alexis Biet toute cette
mobilisation finalement pour pas
grand-chose la position du président n'a
pas changé c'est le Parlement qui devra
trancher la mobilisation a été
considérable énorme on nait pas vu ça je
crois depuis bien des dizaines d'années
en France et en plein mois de janvier
hein donc c'est une mobilisation très
très importante
maintenant nous ce que nous demandons ce
que nous demandions puisque vous venez
de le citer il y a un refus c'était
qu'il y ait un grand débat national sur
ce sujet-là parce que c'est un sujet qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas simple hein et
nous avons voté en conseil municipal une
motion avec pratiquement l'unanimité
hein je dirais du conseil pour demander
ce grand débat national parce que les
les les choses ne sont pas aussi
évidentes que ça et aussi simple que ça
forte mobilisation il y a 15 jours et
finalement la position du président qui
ne change pas votre avis parce que je
pense qu'en fait très simple très
sincèrement je pense que le ce dossier
en fait a été mal présenté et le
président de la République aujourd'hui
défend une idée qui au départ paraître
tout à fait égalitaire je comprends très
bien qui correspond à l'aspiration de on
va dire la communauté homosexuelle je
comprends très bien la chose la seule
chose c'est que depuis qu'enfin a
commencé ce débat on se rend compte
qu'il y a finalement plein d'autres
conséquences je parlerai des
conséquences sur l'adoption mais il y a
plein d'autres conséquences et
finalement ça va beaucoup plus loin que
l'idée de départ et tout ce qu'on a pu
faire avec la mobilisation et tout ce
qui se prépare encore parce parce que
celle du 13 n'est pas la mobilisation
finale c'est la c'était la première
mobilisation c'est le 2 février la
prochaine mobilisation voilà là c'est
des des mobilisations vis-à-vis des
préfectures mais l'idée c'est qu'en fait
de je dirais d'alerter et de faire
comprendre qu'il y a en fait plein
d'autres conséquences qui je pense en
plus en toute honêteté ceux qui ont
proposé ce projet au départ n'avaient
peut-être pas vu toutes ces conséquences
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le président
de la République il est d'une certaine
manière engagé par sa promesse et quand
il dit qu'il a été élu que c'était dans
sa dans son programme c'est vrai mais je
pense que ça a été insuffisamment
préparé que maintenant qu'on découvre
l'ensemble des conséquences et qui ne
s'arrête pas qu'à l'adoption l'ensemble
des conséquences il y a effectivement
une crispion du pays et je pense que
c'est ce message c'est ce message qui
est pas compris en ce moment c'est qu'il
y a vraiment une crispion autour du
sujet Sandrine grangom pour le Parti
socialiste oui c'est quoi c'est une
promesse de campagne qu'ils se sont
obligés de tenir Françis absument pas ça
alors le on découvre pas le sujet ça
fait un on a déjà eu ce débat au moment
du Pax donc la réflexion elle existe
depuis des dizaines d'années dans ce
pays on a suivi aussi ce qui se passait
dans les les autres pays en Espagne VO
les évolutions qui ont été proposées
dans dans d'autres pays il se trouve que
à un moment donné voilà il faut il faut
faire avancer les choses et pour faire
avancer les choses il faut à moment
donné que la loi elle soit présentée
discutter voter donc les les
associations les partis politiques ça
fait déjà longtemps qu'on qu'on a eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer de se
confronter à ce thème et c'est suite à
ces débats un peu partout dans la
société que cette proposition a a émergé
comme une avancée absolument
indispensable aujourd'hui pour répondre
à des questions qui se pose et pour
lesquel on nait pas de réponse donc à un
moment donné il faut apporter des
réponses et on peut pas éternellement
dire qu'il faut débattre débattre
débattre pour arver à en fait repousser
quelque chose dans le temps qui doit à
un moment donné être tranché et c'est le
rôle de nos parlementaires et
l'assemblée national et du Sénat de
trancher Aurore berger pour l'UMP alors
je le rappelle he votre position est un
peu particulière vous défendez cette
réforme au final de mariage pour tous à
l'UMP on est plutôt opposé vous avez
fait connaître votre position à travers
un billet sur le site du nouvelle
observateur d'ailleurs ensuite quelques
élus UMP se sont aussi déclarés
favorables ils vous ont un petit peu
suivi quel regard vous vous avez
là-dessus alors déjà pour répondre à la
première partie je suis assez d'accord
sur la méthode qui a été employée par le
gouvernement et le président de la
République à mon avis n'est pas
forcément la bonne c'estàdire que d'un
côté il a refusé finalement qu'il a un
véritable débat qui s'ouvre et en même
temps il n'a pas fait voter la loi
immédiatement il aurait pu tout à fait
faire en sorte que cette loi soit une
priorité et soit votée dès l'été donc je
pense qu'il y a eu en effet une période
de flou et qui en effet une crispation
dans la société qui moi me gêne et qui
me gêne aussi et vous m'excuserez parce
que la libération de la parole homophobe
que moi je ressens et je ne suis pas la
seule à le ressentir me gêne et me
choque et c'est aussi pour ça je sais
que ça n'est pas votre cas sauf que à un
moment dans un certain nombre
d'arguments qui sont avancés contre le
mariage pour tous on ressent cette
libération de la parole homophobe force
de laisser trop de place à la discussion
ça dérape quelquefois bah on laisse de
la place à la discussion sans en laisser
et puis c'est vrai que François Hollande
qui tarde à recevoir les opposants pour
finalement dire avant de les recevoir
que de toute façon il ne se passera rien
de nouveau je suis pas sûr que la
méthode soit bonne et je suis en tout
cas sûr d'une chose c'est que là où on
aurait pu finalement avoir cette fameuse
société apaisée réconciliée dont nous
parlait François Hollande pendant sa
campagne et au début de son mandat on a
une société qui est très crispée qui se
radicalise probablement des deux côtés
ça c'est une évidence c'est un constat
et c'est un constat d'échec qui je pense
qu'on peut tous partager ici euh cent
grande du Parti socialiste n'est pas
d'accord avec vous pense que si la
méthode avait été meilleure on nurait
peut-être pas eu ces mobilisations on
aurait peut-être pas eu ces crispations
et on aurait peut-être pas eu ce niveau
de tension qu'on atteint aujourd'hui
dans ce pays puis d'ailleurs même
François Hollande lui-même quand il a
parlé de liberté de conscience pour les
maires on sent bien qu'il y a eu un
moment de flottement on sent bien qu'il
est pas tout à fait à l'aise qu'il sait
pas lui-même exactement où il veut aller
donc tout ça sont des arguments qui sont
utilisés par les opposants et puis ça
met aussi les partisans de ce projet
assez mal à l'aise parce qu'il disent
finalement où est la volonté où est-ce
qu'on en est on va parler du fond
justement vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi sur le fond vous êtes d'accord
peut-être vous souhaitez réagir sur la
forme justement qui était dénoncée la
par pas j'ai pas du tout de d'étatame
par rapport au projet il y a pas de
crise passion en tout cas ceux qui sont
favorables à ce projet alors moi je
comprends pas trop la ce débat sur à la
fois on va trop vite on va pas assez
vite enfin à un moment donné il y a il y
a le temps de la discussion moi j'engage
tous ceux qui sont intéressés par le
sujet à aller sur les sites de
l'Assemblée nationale voir les débats
qui sont filmés qui sont très très
intéressant on é en audition donc a pas
y a pas d'échang bah si y a il y a des
auditions qui sont faites qui permettent
aussi aux citoyens de s'approprier ce
sujet et puis à un moment donné il faut
passer par par la loi et donc passer
devant vousz pas l'impression qu'il a eu
un débat de discussionis rép madame moi
j'ai été entendu en audition officielle
par heran Binet que je salue le député
socialiste rapporteur du projet on a eu
une conversation je dirais courtoise
mais ça pas été un débat et un échange
d'idée parce que c'est un peu à l'image
de ce que François Holland dit
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire je vous reçois
mais de toute façon ça changera rien
donc c'est pas ça un débat et que ça se
passe à l'Assemblée nationale ou dehors
c'est pas ça un débat et c'est bien le
problème et ce qui je confirme ce que
dit Madame sur la crisepation c'est
qu'on a pas l'impression d'être dans un
départ on a l'impression de taper sur un
mur et en plus dès qu'on avance des
argument tout de suite la paradripos
c'est vous êtes homophobe je dis au sens
large pas spécialement certains
individus vous êtes homophobe alors que
c'est pas de l'homophobie du tout dont
il s'agit dans ce problème làà seulement
on n'est pas dans un débat on est dans
on a décidé et la porte est fermée et on
l'a vécu à l'Assemblée en audition
officielle vous pourvez prendre les
rapports j'ai été entendu moi je n'ai
vraiment ressenti aucun sentiment
d'homophobie dans la grande
manifestation du 13 janvier mais
franchement aucun et je pense que
écoutez je les ai pas vu hein vraiment
et dans la grande majorité vraiment j'ai
pas j'ai pas vraiment ressenti ça et
simplement je pense qu'il y a eu un
petit peu tromperie dans la promesse
électorale de François Hollande ou euh
de dire je je veux le mariage pour tous
je veux dire qui peut s'opposer à ça euh
et je pense que les jeunes sont ont été
très sensibles à à cela et et et et
n'ont pas vu derrière tout tout ce qu'il
y avait mais pour cela il fallait lancer
un débat et un débat qui puisse s'ouvrir
peut-être sur des nouvelles propositions
là il y a vraiment des des des
confusions moi je suis tout à fait
favorable à ce qu'il y ait une union
civile Enie pour les couples homosexuels
mais de parler de mariage alors que le
mariage c'est autre chose et que c'est
en plus un sacrement pour certaines
religions je veux dire on est là dans la
confusion la plus total et je pense que
ce débat aurait pu permettre d'avancer
des solutions alors deux choses la
première sur l'union civile je le
regrette 1000 fois mais c'était dans le
projet de Nicolas Sarkozi en 2007 il y
avait l'union civile il y avait le
statut du beauparent on a eu une
convention UMP de la Famille Nadine
Morano qui était ministre de la Famille
s'est exprimé et elle a dit les choses
clairement oui j'ai voulu présenter ce
projet de loi à l'Assemblée nationale je
n'avais pas la majorité pour le voter
nous avions 5 ans pour le voter nous
n'avions pas la majorité parlementaire
pour le voter et donc malheureusement
l'UMP aujourd'hui à mon sens n'est pas
crédible quand elle demande uniquement
l'union civile les statut du beau-parent
on a eu 5 ans pour le faire on l'a pas
fait c'est pas la faute de Nicolas
Sarkozi qui avait la volonté politique
de le faire qui s était ni ministre de
la Famille qui a présenté le projet mais
malheureusement on avait pas la majorité
parlementaire pour voter ce texte et
c'est la ministre enfin l'ancienne
ministre elle-même qui l'a rappelé ce
matin dans une convention deuxième point
quand on parle de sac pas faire de débat
làdessus à l'époque aussi c'est un peu
compliqué aujourd'hui de revenir en
disant notre seule proposition est une
proposition qu'on aurait pu mettre en
œuvre et qu'on n pas mise en
œuvre on peut faire notre coupa làdessus
mais malheureusement je trouve que c'est
un peu j'ai comme argument uniquement
aujourd'hui de de le brandir même si
c'est une avancée d'autre part par
rapport au sacrement il s'agit pas du
mariage religieux il s'agit du mariage
civil on est dans une société laïque
donc je je ne comprends pas l'argument
qui est de dire que le mot mariage gêne
je ne comprends pas l'argument qui est
de dire que et puis de toute façon on ne
retire rien à ceux qui veulent continuer
à se marier religieusement on ne leur
enlève rien on ne leur enlève aucun
droito
j'ai vous souhatiez réagir juste Alex a
2 secondes par rapport à ce que dit
bergeris tout à fait d'accord vous dites
qu'il y a de la confusion mais enfin
vous créez de la confusion en mélangeant
plusieurs choses en mélangeant
effectivement mariage civil et mariage
religieux là on est bien dans le mariage
civil le terme n'appartient pas aux
églises ce terme n'est pas un terme qui
appartient aux églises c'est un terme
qui appartient à la République le
mariage voilà donc donc c'est c'est là
où on est on est en plein désaccord donc
là il y a confusion qui est
enteten malureusement récente la répu
mais c'est une conquête justement de la
réui et de la laïcité justement de
s'approprier de s'approprier c la
deuxème confusion qui est entretenue
c'est aussi entre le mariage pour tous
et tous les problèmes qui sont liés à la
famille et comment on pense la famille
aujourd'hui qui fera l'objet d'un autre
texte de loi où il faudra aussi avoir
une réflexion globale sur c'est quoi
aujourd'hui la famille en France
qu'est-ce qu'on entend par famille et je
pense qu'il faut déconnecter aussi ces
deux sujets et je pense c'était une
bonne chose qu'il est été décidé que
dans ce texte là on ne parle que de
d'union enfin de mariage civil entre
deux personnes du même sexe donc
changement de loi qui me paraît
indispensable dans le sens du progrès on
va parler du fond justement vous allez n
explier ch un souit oui mais c'est pas
un progrès vous allez vous expliquer
chacun pourquoi vous êtes pour pourquoi
vous êtes contre on va rentrer un petit
peu plus dans le détail dans le fond
juste un micro trottoir la rue doit-elle
faire reculer le gouvernement c'est la
question que nous avons posée moi je
pense que les gens doivent
s'exprimer et qui doivent en tenir
compte il y a une opinion importante
faut tenir compte des gens mais il va y
avoir un débat à l'Assemblée je pense
que ça va rien changer
oui d'après les médias ce que j'entends
je pense pas malheureusement j'ai pas
l'impression pour parce que je pense
qu'ils ont décidé qu'ils le feront je
pense pas si ça si ça va être fait je
pense qu'ils arriveront à le faire oui
moi je pense que oui et pourquoi ben
parce que là il voit bien qu'il y a trop
trop de monde qui sont hostil au projet
donc je pense qu'ils peuvent revoir leur
copies en fait c'est possible bah non si
veut passer il passera de toute façon
qu'il y a du monde ou
pas et nous parlons ce soir une fois de
plus du mariage pour tous avec cette
manifestation qui s'annonce pour ce
weekend des partisans et qui seront
présents donc dans la rue notamment Berg
vous y serez pourquoi vous allez
défendre ce projet de loi sur le fond
concrètement sur le fond alors moi j'ai
fait un un long cheminement aussi par
rapport à à ce projet c'est vrai que
dans l'absolu et je pense qu'on peut
tous le dire on préférerait avoir une
famille avec une altérité un père une
mère des enfants sauf que la famille a
changé point et à un moment
malheureusement enfin malheureusement ou
heureusement il faut juste prendre acte
que les familles sont différé il faut
répondre à la réalité qui existe déjà un
papa une maman et accè mieux pour un
enfant très bien on fait quoi des
familles monoparentales on dit quoi aux
mères qui élèvent seul leurs enfants on
leur dit qu'elles ne sont pas légitimes
à les élever parce qu'elles sont seuls
queles que soient les circonstances dans
lesquelles elles se sont retrouvées on
dit quoi aux enfants des familles
homoparentales qui sont des dizaines de
milliers on leur dit que l'amour qui a
prédestiné à leur venu dans ce couple
n'est pas légitime on leur dit que le
couple que forment leurs parents
puisqu'ils sont des parents n'est pas
légitime on leur dit donc qu'il ne
devrait pas être dans ses familles quel
message on délivre aujourd'hui notamment
aux enfants qui existent et qui
continueront à exister d'ailleurs loi ou
pas loi je veux dire la loi n'existe pas
et pour autant ces enfants sont là donc
ça veut dire que même si la loi n'était
pas votée ces enfants continueraient à
être là il y a environ entre 100000 et
300000 enfants qui vivent dans des
familles hent avecun des de con qui n
pas et bien justement c'était un des
points de la conversation à l'Assemblée
nationale avec le
députéan binet c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de toutes ces familles là et la
question à laquelle on a répondu
ensemble c'est comment on en est arrivé
là et on en est arrivé là depuis
1966 avec la loi qui a permis l'adoption
non non mais l'adoption par une personne
ce qui est très simple si on veut
arrêter arrêter c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour sécuriser juridiquement les
enfants qui sont dans ces famill bien
traitons traitons ce problème là et
créons un cadre spécifique à cette
situation là mais ne permettons pas par
la loi de continuer cette situation et
d'augmenter de manière croissanteadre
juque et bien c'est d'arrêter d'abroger
la loi de 66 qui était parfaitement dans
les sujets à l'étude pour interdire pas
à question c'estàd que vous dites on
veut faire en sorte que ça ne se
reproduise plus je parle pas de ça je
vous dis ça va continuer exist vous
n'êcherez jamais une femme d'avoir un
enfant par exemple c'est plus compliqué
pour de hommes mais vous n'empêcherez
jamais une femme qui veut un enfant d'en
avoir un fait mais que faites-vous donc
pour ces enfants qui sont là et qui
continueront à arriver vous pouvez pas
juste leur dire on va abroger la loi qui
fait qu'un célibataire peut adopter et
qui est d'ailleurs tout à fait hypocrite
et qui a d'ailleurs répondu à l'époque
par le général de GA à une situation qui
était une situation de crise Guer et on
est d'accord làdessus mais aujourd'hui
elle est hypocrite tout le monde le dit
donc c'est sujet n'est pas juste
abrogons la loi qui permet au
célibataires d'adopter c'est que fait-on
mais que faites-vous pour ces enfants
qui qui existent mais on adore on adorit
avoir ce débat et c'est ce qu'on a vu
avec non mais justement c'est de trouver
cette solution là je pense qu'il peut
exister un statut temporaire mais il ne
peut être mais oui temporaire
c'est-à-dire je vais traiter la
situation de ces enfants qui sont dans
cette situation aujourd'hui et il faut
effectivement trouver la solution mais
le problème d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
est en train de de de lever
définitivement tout obstacle et ça va se
démultiplier et on va arriver
un problème majeur et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on vous dit que le
mariage c'est pas la solution n'arri pas
un problème majeur puisque si demain il
y a le mariage et que ces enfants
naissent dans le cadre d'un couple marié
qu'il soit hétérosexuel ou homosexuel
ils auront le même niveau de sécurité
juridique
doncite le débat le débat existe vous
voyez au sein de de l'UMP on a des
positions différentes ce qui n'est pas
le cas malheureusement au Parti
socialiste qui devra avoir un vote
bloqué pour faire passer cette loi on
voit bien qu'il a une volonté de la
faire de la discussion qui a entre de
représentants de ce soir si on pouvait
rester sur le sujet et pas refaire les
discussions au sein de l'UMP on le sait
que les discussions au sein de l'UMP ont
lieu on l' bien suivi ces derniers mois
dans les médias au-delà de ça pour
revenir sur ce sujet cette réaction sur
ces questions par exemple les réponsesg
posé la question qu quelle réponse on
apporte à ces familles où il y a un
couple homosexuel un seul des deux
parents qui a une légitimité l'autre
n'en a pas pour avoir adopté moi je je
je pense que que il y a toujours besoin
d'un père et d'une mère et que on pense
là trop je pense trop au droit des
adultes d'avoir un enfant mais est-ce
qu'on se place vis-à-vis de l'enfant qui
a un droit d'avoir un père et une mère
et pour moi cette loi elle est le
SOMUM de la société de consommation
c'est-àdire que vraiment on fait des
enfants une une matière une marchandise
derrière il va y avoir forcément la la
PMA la la GPA forcément pour aller dans
au bout jusqu'à l'égalitarisme voulu par
le
gouvernementob et et
et on va arriver à ce qu'il y ait d'une
part d'assécher l'adoption puisqueon a
des tas de pays qui vont refuser de
donner des enfants à la France et
ensuite on va arriver à ce qu'il y ait
un trafic à ce qu'il y ait une
marchandise une marchandisation du
ventre des mes il faut avoir tout ça je
pense en tête quand on se lance dans
dans un tel projet et je regrette encore
nous regrettons vraiment énormément
qu'il n'y ait pas eu ce débat mais pas
uniquement entre parlementaires ou entre
gens nous aussi on est je dirais un peu
entre gens initiés hein mais vraiment
dans dans le fond de la population qui a
pas eu ce débat de de lancer c'est c'est
c'est méprisé je trouve le peuple mais
ensuite je passerai la parole pour
parler de la question de l'adoption
justement je crois qu'on là on voit bien
qu'il y a une coupure très très grande
entre vous et nous en tout cas entre
vous et moi sur sur la conception qu'on
a de ce qu'est la famille aujourd'hui et
vous avez en tête un modèle qui est un
modèle dépassés qui serait un modèle qui
ne pourrait en fait il y a une on voit
bien qu'il y a une hiérarchie dans ce
que vous vous présentez d'un modèle qui
serait le le meilleur modèle donc le
couple hétérosexuel avec enfant ou par
définition l'fant pourrait s'épanouir
dans ce modèle là mieux que dans les
autres et je pense que là il y a une une
coupure idéologique de fond moi je
pensintért l'fant d'abord l'intérêt de
l'enfant c'est parfois d'avoir deux
parents et deux parents si
désolé résumé à deux parents aimants
c'est pas ça de parents aimants c'est
c'est avec un enfant c'est une famille
qui a autant de valeur et qui n'est pas
hiérarchiquement moins une famille ou
moins reconnaissable comme tel
que donc et je pense que pour le coup
quand je parle de de lois de progrès et
et et de force la conservatrice et qui
pour moi sont réactionnaire c'est parce
qu'on a une une vision de la société qui
est pas la même et je pense que vous
êtes en décalage avec les attentes
profondes alors il y avait du monde pour
manifester c'est clair mais il y aura du
monde aussi pour manifester dimanche et
je crois que vous êtes en décalage avec
ce qu'est aujourd'hui la société
française et et à un moment donné ça a
été rappelé il y a des questions de fond
qui se posent et vous apportez comme
réponse comme ça pose plein de problèm
alors on traite pas mais si il faut
traiter et traiter tous les problèmes un
par un et notamment à un moment donné
c'est pas dans la loi il faut bien le
rappeler il y aura plus tard la question
qui sera posée de la PMA et de la
gestation pour autruit mais qui qui se
pose indifféremment pour tous les
couples et il faudra qu'on qu'on qu'on
pense la GP pour tous les couples aussi
d' peu importe de hommes de femmes voilà
c'est pour moi c'est pas c'est pas le
problème de la nature du couple qui se
POS c'est est-ce qu'on autorise la GPA
en France moi j'y suis opposé mais pour
pour n'importe quel couple
indépendamment cette question du mariage
pour qui nous occupe ce soir même si
effectivement découle GPA PMA on l'a
bien compris que c'est tout ça c un
dossier un dossier lié et que vous
vouliez l'aborder on y reviendra si vous
le souhaitez mais Ben concernant
l'adoption voilà je j'aurai 60 réponses
à vous faire mais je vais en prendre une
je pense que vous avez la chance vous
madame de connaître votre père et votre
mère vous également c'estàd celui et
celle qui vous ont donné la vie rien
voilà vous portez d' d' voilà voilà ce
que je veux dire c'est que dans
l'adoption le problème principal c'est
que justement vous ne connaissez pas vos
origines une adoption réussie c'est
lorsque ceux à qui on vous a confié
parce que je rappelle que l'adoption
c'est donner une famille à un enfant
c'est pas l'inverse alors je pense que
c'est tout le problème en ce moment des
décalages dans les discours c'est que
dans le projet on va donner un enfant à
un couple qui n'en a pas l'adoption
c'est le contraire c'est pour ça que
nous les l'association des adoptés on
monte au créneau pour rappeler ce
qui'est l'adoption or je pense
qu'aujourd'hui dans le projet de loi on
parle pas du tout d'adoption l'adoption
c'est un enfant qui est né qui a été
abandonné et à qui on va donner une
espèce de deuxième chance et une
deuxième famille bon qu'est-ce qu'une
adoption réussie c'est quand l'enfant
peut parfaitement s'identifier à ça on
va dire nouvelle famille moi je sais
très bien que c'est pas ma mère qui m'a
porté néanmoins c'est pleinement ma mère
et l'expression famille adoptive pardon
mère adoptive n'existe pas dans une
adoption réussie c'est pleinement ma
mère et c'est pleinement mon père même
si je sais que biologiquement c'est pas
le cas il s'avère qu'on m'a envoyé
beaucoup d'enfants dans ma situation
dont les adoptions n'avaient pas marché
dans des couples hétérosexuels donc je
je précise pas homosexuels ou
hétérosexuel dans des couples
hétérosexuels quand l'adoption ne
fonctionne pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
identification qu'est-ce qui se passe il
y a une volonté on en a beaucoup parlé à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat d'aller
rechercher ses origines et Erwan Binet a
dit que dans le prochain projet de loi
sur la famille il y aurait un volet sur
le secret des origines croyez-moi ça
représente qu'une cinquantaine de cas
chaque fois que l'enfant va chercher ses
origines c'est une catastrophe alors
vous trouverez toujours à la télé le cas
de celui qui dans 9000 % des cas ce que
je veux dire avec ça c'est que dans les
couples homosexuels l'enfant ne pourra
pas s'identifier parce qu'il va
mécaniquement en manquer un soit la mère
soit le père et donc évidemment c'est
pas à l'âge de 5 ans c'est pas à l'âge
de 12 ans qu'on comprend ces chosesl
c'est plus tard rendez bien compte vous
rendez bien compte vous êes en train de
dire vous êtes déjà en train de dire bah
puisque ça marchera pas avec les
parents les ce que je veux vous dire
Madame c'est que ces enfants vous les
privz de la possibil de pouvoir
s'identifier et de se donner une vie
donc mécaniquement ils vont aller sur la
recherche des origines c'est comme si on
vous demandait aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous êtes prêt à envoyer des enfants sur
un terrain miné oui ils peuvent passer
au travers sans sans être blessés
peut-être tous les exemples qu'on a
c'est que malheureusement les enfants
qui vont chercher ses origines parce
queil y a pas identification et
malheureusement les dégâts sont beaucoup
plus graves et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
le projet va mettre des enfants où
mécaniquement il peut pas avoir deux
pères et deux mères il y a bien un
moment il y a eu une mère ù il y a eu un
père recherche des origines explosion de
l'enfant voilà c'est ça le témoignage
c'est pour ça que nous on monte au
créneau pour dire attention on appelle
adoption quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
pardon n'est pas de l'adoption c'est
simplement le souhait d'adulte que je
peux comprendre je comprends très bien
la volonté de paternité ou de maternité
qui veulent un enfant mais ça s'appelle
pas l'adoption et c'est ça le grand
danger aujourd'hui c'est que ces enfants
mécaniquement et encore une fois c'est
pas à 5 ans c'est pas 8 ans c'est
beaucoup plus tard qu'on le comprend
qu'on se dire mais alors d'où je viens
qui était mon père qui
c tout votre argumentation part de
présupposé sur lequel je par d'ppord dès
le départ voilà c'estàd que on peut pas
s'identifier à deux je suis désolé hein
chacun s qualité hein mais donc on peut
pas s'identifier à deux à deux personnes
deux parents qui seraient du même sex et
pourquoi mais d' d'où on sort ça d'où
vous sortez vous avez des analyses qui
disent queon peut pas dans certains cas
on peut pas s'identifier un père parce
que tout simplement le père ne joue pas
son rôle de père mais c'est c'est pas
lié au au sexe c'est lié à la
personnalité c'est lié à la manière
d'ébut père même si Onna on se construit
parfois par rapport à un grand-père
parfois pas du tout par rapport à un
père surt père dit quand a pas de père
alors fait des enfants moins équilibrés
j'en suis pas sûr parfois c'est même
mieux juste enfin plusieurs remarques la
première quand on dit qu'en fait les les
couples homosexuels en fait il y aurait
une sorte de marchandisation de l'enfant
parce que on serait là pour combler un
désir d'enfant mais dans un couple
hétérosexuel qu'est-ce qu'il y a
finalement de plus égste que de faire un
enfant on fait pas un enfant pour
l'enfant qui va naître on fait un enfant
parce que il y a un projet parental on
fait un enfant parce qu'on a envie
d'avoir un enfant que ce soit dans un
couple hétérosexuel dans un couple
homosexuel pourquoi dans un couple
homosexuel tout d'un coup il y aurait
que le droit à l'enfant pas de droit de
l'enfant et dans le casadre du couple
hétérosexuel les couples hétérosexuels
penseraient tous avant tout au droit de
l'enfant c'est un peu réducteur on sait
tous enfin je suis pas encore maman mais
enfin il me semble quand même pour
l'avoir vu autour de moi qu'à un moment
on a un désir d'enfant et que ce désir
d'enfant il est quand même assez même
s'il est construit pensé il peut être
assez égoïste je vois pas en quoi il
serait différent que l'on soit
hétérosexuel homosexuel d'autre part sur
la question de
l'adoption je comprends les les les
inquiétudes que vous soulevez mais le
problème c'est que dans ces cas là vous
pourriez juste être opposé à l'adoption
mais vous êtes aussi opposé au mariage
civil étendu aux personnes de même sexe
donc c'est je sais pas si je l'ai pas
encore en tous les cas dit maintenant
mais je à moins que il meble que vous
êtes all à
Mar contre le mar donc il meble priori
une marche contre le mariage pour T plôt
H mais je vais même être encore plus
clair pour parce que ça ça parit
l'objectif l'objectif du projet sur
l'aspect adoption je parle je parle pas
du mariage sur l'aspect adoption très
honnêtement aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
d'aller adopter un enfant comme moi
c'est-à-dire un enfant déjà né et
abandonné les communauté homosexuelle
que j'ai pu rencontrer m'ont dit mais
c'est pas ça qu'ils veulent ils veulent
la faculté d'adoption comment on l'a par
le mariage parce que automatique en
France et après c'est d'avoir eux-mêmes
leurs propres enfants en vue d'adoption
et c'est le cœur et c'est le fond du
projet des voix sélevé en disant
attention on va droit vers le mariage
l'adoption et vous les socialistes
puisque c'estabeth Guigou qui disait dis
mais non vous êtes en train d'agiter un
mouchoir et ceter on est X années après
on est làdessus nous on vous dit
aujourd'hui que le mochoir qu'on agite
c'est que même m si c'est pas au départ
votre souhait au sens éthique du terme
on va droit vers cette PMA
industrialisée et cette GPA
pour Mme à
l'assemblé c'est marqué merci à tous les
quatre reste en plateau encore quelques
instants on va juste se rendre du côté
de l'Université de versailles-
Saint-Quentin pour conclure ce plateau
dimanche vous le savez ce sont les
partisans de cette réforme qui font
défiler une association étudiante
l'association ICAR humanitaire demain
vendredi propose notamment aux étudiants
de se réunir de préparer la mobilisation
ensemble et puis il y a également une
autre association politique celle-ci
l'UNEF et nous avons rencontré sa
présidente eux aussi se charge
d'organiser une mobilisation avec les
étudiants sur 50 ans moi je représente
un syndicat étudiants et l'UNEF a fait
le choix depuis bah depuis longtemps de
s'engager au côté de la cause des LGBT
puisque nous on considère que l'égalité
des droits c'est bah c'est ce qu'il y a
de plus important donc aujourd'hui on
fait le constat que avec la loi actuelle
et bien les homosexuels ne peuvent pas
fonder une une famille par rapport au
coupllees hétérosexuel et donc ça
concerne aussi les étudiants puisqu'il y
a des étudiants homosexuels et donc
voilà l'UNF s'engage au côté de
l'égalité et comme cette organisation le
syndicat étudiant s'engage au côté de la
côte de la cause LGBT nous engageons
aussi bah dans la cause contre le
racisme et aussi contre le sexisme voilà
donc c'est une des causes qu'on défend
aujourd'hui on peut constater que en
effet il y a une partie de la population
française qui a exprimé son refus quant
à quant au projet de loi du gouvernement
euh bon on peut moi personnellement je
ça ne me décourage pas parceque je pense
que la cause pour l'égalité est un
combat qui n'est jamais terminé et
aujourd'hui on a la chance justement
d'avoir un gouvernement qui va dans le
sens de l'élargissement des droits et
d'une progression des droits pour une
partie de la population donc je pense
qu'il faut à tout prix soutenir ce
projet de loi et quant au quant à la
partie quant à la à la population qui
bah s'est exprimé contre je trouve ça
vraiment regrettable d'autant plus qu'on
a pu assister à des des dérapages des
réflexions complètement homophobe autant
de la part de la population que de la
part d'hommes politiques et je pense que
c'est inacceptable c'est pour ça que la
manifestation de dimanche prochain de
dimanche 27 c'est vraiment extrêmement
important qu'on soit le plus nombreux
possible c'est pour ça que l'UNEF se
mobilise également pour qu'il y ait un
maximum de jeunes dans la rue et pour
exprimer la vraie voix de de la France
la France qui est pour l'égalité des
droits entre les hétéros et les homos il
y a des sondages qui sont sortis et qui
prouvent queil y a plus de 70 % de la
population jeune en tout cas puisque là
je fais partie duf en tout cas en ce qui
concerne les jeunes il y a plus de 70%
qui sont prêts à accepter ce ce mariage
et même l'acceptation de de l'adoption
et de la procréation médicalement
assistée donc oui je pense que la
population est prête pour ce projet de
loi et puis j'ai envie de dire que bah à
un moment donné la loi doit aussi être
initiatrice de de de de l'égalité des
droits et et de toute façon la
population je pense oui est prête à
accueillir cette
égalité très brièvement pardon et pour
conclure benoî sacernant vous souhaitiz
réagir juste par rapport au fait que
l'UNEF on discute au sein de
l'université visiblement là dans
l'enseignement ça a pas l'air de poser
de problème à ce qu'on appelle une manif
or il y a quelques temps on a reçu une
lettre du ministre de l'éducation comme
quoi on avait pas à mettre dans les
écoles ce débat que c'était interdit que
machin demanda différentignement supé
visiblement ça a l'air d'être différent
parce que c'est la fac oui bah oui c'est
diff rappel elle est bien placée elle
est bien placée pour en parler c'est que
l'uni le faisait aussi mais heureusement
a une conscience politique et syndicale
qui fonctionne dans l'enseignement
supérieur c'est bien c'est bien que les
jeunes a envie de s'engager sont majeur
ça change aussi beaucoup une toute
dernière question ils était entre 300000
et 800000 ça fait une grande fourchette
voir 1 million il y a 15 jours à
manifester si vous êtes moins nombreux
ce weekend ce sera un échec symbolique
non on n'est pas dans des des courses au
chiffres ça pas beaucoup de sens on a
manifesté en décembre l'idée c'est à un
moment donné de d'aller exprimer une
opinion après on sait bien que on est
sur des comptabilités délirantes o on
sort des chiffres on sait pas trop où et
et ça devient un peu d'ailleurs
problématique quelle que soit la
manifestation et qui manifeste hein de
d'avoir des chifffres
n qu'onve pas dans pays àir combien on a
de personn dans une rue
quo du monde y a 15 jours il y aura du
monde dimanche je peux vous l'assurer
merci à tous les qure d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau et puis deux
autres informations qui concernent
toujours ce mariage pour tous puisque
nous sommes dans les ivelines à l'UMP je
vais citer le point de vue d'enry gu
député de la 3e circonscription il
demande un référendum il est devenu la
tête d'affiche de l'Entente
parlementaire pour la famille qui réunit
217 puté sinateur il va publier un livre
également contre le mariageier qui sera
publié le Samedi 25 janvier une
cinquantaine de pages disponibles en
kiosque le titre n'est pas encore révélé
et puis toujours dans les ivelines l'une
des alliés de l'UMP Christine Boutin
avec le Parti Chrétien Démocrate
également conseillère général du canton
de Rambouillet qui a publié l'ouvrage
tous unis pour le mariage avec une
préface de Jean-Frédéric Poisson député
de la 10e circonscription des Yvelines
une fois de plus merci à vous quatre on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler organiser
ce cette petite table ronde et c'était
pas la première j'invite d'ailleurs les
téléspectateurs à revoir toutes nos
émissions toutes ces séquences sur notre
site internet dans un instant la
chronique de l'économie auparavant du
sport et cette mauvaise nouvelle pour le
club de Montini le bretonne qui devait
affronter le PSG en Coupe de France
féminine le match est reporté mais pour
le mercredi après-midi difficile pour le
coach du club amateur local de mobiliser
ses joueuses en pleine
semaine ce match devait être une fête
pour tous les inim Montin mais ce 32e de
finale de la Coupe de France de football
féminin entre Montini et le PSG se
transforme en calvaire suite aux fortes
chutes de neige les terrains de football
ivelinois sont impraticables et le stade
de La Coudre n'y échappe pas programmé à
l'origine ce dimanche 27 janvier à 14h30
la rencontre est d'abord reportée par la
Fédération française de football au
mercredi 30 à 14h30 aussi puis
finalement à 20h la déception
inimentaine est grande au
jourdaujourd'hui c'est plus une fête
parce que mettre un match à 14h30 c'est
aberérrant pour les filles parce que les
filles travaillent on n pas des pros
elles sont pas ell travaillent terment à
18h VO 19h le soir ben on va composer
parce que là j'ai pas de terrain les
terrains sont fermés on va s'entraîner
en salle on va aller faire des footings
et on va essayer de trouver une solution
j'ai une semaine pour trouver une
solution et trouver des filles aptes à
jouer mercredi prochain les tribunes du
terrain d'honneur du stade de La Coudre
resteront vided la rencontre va devoir
se jouer sur le terrain synthétique du
club seule surface jouable du côté
inimontin on crie au favoritisme les
dates de report proposées par le club
cquantinois le 3 et le 10 février ne
convenaient pas au parisgermain alors
tout simplement il se trouve que ce sont
des des des des semaines internationales
et que voilà nous nous avons beaucoup
d'international on peut pas présenter
une équipe contre Montini
euh voilà c'est c'est ces dates là donc
il est tout à fait normal que la
Fédération trouve une date en dehors des
dates les filles de jeanani Grosset
auront en tout cas une motivation de
plus pour renverser l'ogre parisien
mercredi soir lors de ce choc classé à
risque match